it's been over 40 days since 22 year old
Masa and Minnie died while in police
custody her family are suing those
involved and despite severe restrictions
sporadic protests continue to take place
for the sixth consecutive week in Iran
women life freedom is one of the many
slogans born out of massa's death
[Music]
there is no organized group or person
behind the demonstrations there are
severe internet restrictions and
hundreds have been arrested so far for
inciting protests
[Music]
on the 40th Day since her death an
occasion that's a long-standing
tradition in Iranian culture to honor
those who have passed away thousands
gathered at her grave site in aichi
Cemetery in her hometown of sakras in
Kurdistan Province and then there were
clashes as the crowds were leaving the
cemetery which resulted in officials
cutting off the internet in the entire
Western province of Kurdistan meanwhile
other protests took place in dozens of
other cities across the country and in
hamadan Province a revolutionary guard
intelligence officer was killed by what
the officials called a rioter officials
here blamed the unrest on foreign
elements the main driving force has been
young women who continue to push the
boundaries of the government
[Applause]
whatever comes next it's clear that Masa
amini's death will be remembered as a
dark chapter in this country's history
that's changed it forever
[Music]